whoa the 14 plus is overheating like mad
Apple finally gave us a large screen
less expensive phone but should you just
spend the extra 200 and get all of the
extra features of the 14 pro Max well
today we are going to cover every single
difference starting from the design and
comfort to the displays the new Dynamic
Island versus the notch the performance
battery life and more I'll be using the
14 pro Max for over two weeks now so I'm
excited to check out this phone and
right away the first thing that stands
out is the weight of this phone and all
these fingerprints that are on this
thing already personally I do think that
the 14 pro Max is a little too heavy so
I prefer the lighter weight and the
crazy thing is that the 14 pro that's
much smaller is actually heavier than
the 14 plus and that is because of the
huge camera system on the 14 pro we're
going to talk about that in just a bit
along with the stainless steel on the
the pro phones compared to aluminum now
I like the shiny stainless steel but it
is a big fingerprint magnet but the plus
side is that it is more durable for drop
protection and other than that all of
the other glass is identical in terms of
hardness now in terms of comfort in the
hand I would definitely give it to the
14 plus just because that shiny back
gives you a lot of extra grip so if you
don't like using a case that is nice
taking a look at the front so the first
thing I notice is of course the dynamic
Island and that regular Notch you guys
let me know which one looks better but
I've been using the dynamic Island for a
few weeks and I love it now when I'm
running a timer it shows up there the
same thing with music it just pops into
there you can see what's playing you
have access to shortcuts Maps pop up
there as well and then it literally is
going to give you directions and this
morning I had a notification there
showing me that my airpods case is low
and I was able to see that so just the
extra convenience is nice and as time
goes on we're gonna get more in more
features added to that instead of just
having that regular Notch the other
thing I noticed is that the bezels are
Slimmer on the 14 pro Max but that's not
a huge difference now there's a lot of
other differences with the screen itself
we'll cover that in just a bit but the
first thing I want to do is test out the
speakers because the 14 pro Max sounds
amazing and I'm hoping that the 14 plus
does as well let's take a listen
I'm so happy that these things
practically sound identical because the
14 pro Max was such an upgrade so
thankfully Apple didn't cheap out on the
speakers on the 14 plus now do you want
to experience twice as fast load times
in Safari on your iPhone iPad and Mac
then download Magic glass with Adblock
which is an efficient high performance
and free ad blocker with over 4 000 5
Star reviews it's incredibly easy to set
up blocks a variety of ads across the
web and now also blocks over 10 types of
YouTube ads so download Magic lasso
Adblock for free from the app store or
use the link below to receive one
month's free access to all of our
sponsors magic lasso adblocks Pro
features now just like magic lasso the
other thing that speeds up your phone is
promotion that is the ability to run at
120hz and then slow all the way down to
one Hertz for the always-on display or
24 Hertz if you're watching a movie now
you guys are seeing some slow motion
shots because it's really kind of hard
to show this off in regular video but in
the real world the 14 pro Max just feels
so smooth compared to slightly stuttery
on the 14 plus now with that said I
think most people are going to buy a 14
plus have not tried Pro motion so you
won't really miss it but if you try both
out it's a big difference now the other
big difference is display brightness I
have these both maxed out in manual and
the 14 pro Max looks slightly brighter
even though you think it's a bigger
difference a thousand nits compared to
800 for typical turning on auto
brightness and stepping outside in the
sun the pro Max is able to reach 2 000
nits compared to about a thousand maybe
1200 on the 14 plus but I gotta be
honest I was expecting a bigger
difference and I'm having a hard time
believing that the 14 plus is limited to
to 800 and that 1200 it looks like it's
actually brighter and apple is under
estimating it now we also have a
difference with HDR video the 14 pro Max
can reach 1600 nits compared to 1200 and
looking at it I can see it's brighter
especially with that motorcycle shot but
for the most part I was expecting a
bigger difference and once again I think
that the 14 plus is actually doing a
better job than what Apple States in
terms of brightness as far as detail
they look the same they're both very
sharp displays contrast looks great and
if we go ahead and stretch out the
videos with the notch I personally think
it's a little bit less distracting even
though it's larger because with the 14
pro Max you have video off to the side
that kind of makes that Dynamic Island
pop a bit more than the regular Notch
but you guys let me know what your
preference is down in the comments and
now let's talk about performance the 14
plus has the a15 bionic with the 5 Core
GPU from last year's Pro phone and the
pro Max has the new a16 now we're going
to test out the performance I'm going to
go ahead and run geekbench's CPU test
but look at that Ram right there I just
have to say with real world use the last
two weeks I have not noticed the 14 pro
Max being any faster than my previous 13
Pro the scores are in and we have a
difference of eight percent and single
core and about 15
in multi-core so even on a percentage
basis it is not huge sure the 14 per Max
a little bit more powerful but I think
the fact that this year Apple added in
six gigs of RAM to the cheaper phones
just like the pros that makes a real
world difference with apps staying open
longer in the background now as far as
graphics performance I'm going to run
the compute test here and both of these
processors have five core graph ethics
last year's 13 had a slower 4 core so
let's see the difference now here we go
with the graphics and the difference is
25
and with that the a16 actually uses a
little bit less power to achieve this
score we'll talk about battery life in
just a sec now I've been gaming with the
14 pro Max and it has done a great job
but I think the bigger deal is just
having a large display it makes it so
much nicer in your hand and with that
even though the a15 is weaker in the
toughest test which is genshin it was
barely any slower so as of now you're
not gonna notice the difference I mean
we do have that promotion display so
some games might look a little smoother
if they're not super tough on the
graphics but I think the bigger deal is
if you're gonna have the 14 plus well
that is when games are going to be
harder and the 14 pro Max will start to
have a bigger difference in performance
now personally what I'm very curious
about is display dimming Apple said that
they improved the thermal performance of
these phones and last year the 13 Pro
Max and the pros they would dim quite a
bit because they got hot so let's reign
in tutu and we'll see how they do whoa
look at that guys the 14 pro Max already
dimmed down whereas the 14 plus has not
now it has less graphics performance so
it's making less frames I mean look at
that right there you guys see that white
page and how much dimmer it is now I did
start with both phones really bright and
matching up and that is what you need if
you're going to be playing outside in a
bright room and unfortunately the 14 pro
Max my personal phone is not doing so
well there you go now the 14 plus dimmed
down as well whoa the 14 plus is
overheating like mad so the 14 pro
started getting too hot quicker but it's
maintaining its performance now let's
grab our thermal camera here as you guys
can see the 14 plus is slightly hotter
but there's a lot more heat there and
it's spread out more so and even now
there's been a minute after the gaming
test the screen is still dimmer on the
14 plus so with that said if you really
care about gaming go for the pro Max and
now let's talk about battery life the 14
plus actually has a larger battery than
the 14 pro Max and with that I have been
disappointed with the battery life from
my 14 pro Max using it with daily use I
mentioned the always-on display for a
brief bit in the beginning it is so
convenient to have that but it does
drain your battery same thing with the
crazy brightness with that 2000 nit
display and it's been worse than my
phone last year now a few people have
done comparisons as far as battery life
detect shop did a good one but with
those you're not testing out standby
time or having the bright display
running so I want to do a real world
battery life where you're actually using
the phone with auto brightness just like
you would in the real world so if you
guys want to see that go ahead and make
sure you guys are subscribed with
notifications enabled but from the
simple test they're showing about 30
minutes more so on the 14 plus and now
the cameras which is probably one of the
biggest reasons somebody want to buy the
14 pro Max it has the extra three times
optical zoom lens that gives you better
quality the new 48 megapixel sensor and
even though the selfie cameras are
identical there is a difference in
processing now I'm actually doing a very
detailed camera comparison testing out
all the modes testing out video and that
should be going up tomorrow so if you
guys want to see that make sure you're
subscribed as well so let me know what
your thoughts is the 14 plus worth the
savings or should you spend the extra
money personally I think you should for
the 14 pro Max check out one of those
great videos right over there and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]